Hey, Jack, how are you?
Hey, Shashank, how you doing?
I'm doing great. How about you? How's everything going on your end?
I am.
I'm very busy this morning. In fact, I was going to ask you, is it possible if we can reschedule this?
Just give me a moment.
Ohh.
12.30
1230 I have a call next week, but Thursday I can do. Next week or this week, or if this week you want, we can do it some other time. I am ready to move it on the same time on next Thursday.
Okay.
Yeah. What's your best availability, you think, next Thursday?
Yeah, Tuesday I'm on leave and Wednesday I have a lot of calls already planned. So that's right.
Okay.
Gotcha. Let's go ahead and set it for Thursday of next week. That looks like the 21st. Is that okay?
Yes, same time.
Okay, I sincerely apologize. I just got a lot of fires this morning.
It's OK.
No, I totally agree. Sometimes we are down with fires. It's okay. So I'll share. I have updated the e-white. Okay. And thanks for coming in and informing me. Me too next week.
Okay, alright.
Yes, I apologize. I'll let you go for now.
No worries. Thanks, sir. Thanks, bye.
Thank you.